[Music]
Second Life is indescribable it's like
World of Warcraft's values it's fun it's
the future of the internet it's fabulous
it's a damn cool place just a very few
hours it's a lot like real life and in
fact it is real life imagine a place
based completely on voluntary exchange a
place without coercion a place where you
can be anything you want to be and
create virtually anything you want to
create sounds utopian right well there's
a whole new world out there folks a
place with unlimited space and no
immigration restrictions in fact in this
new frontier you can fly this is second
life a virtual world developed by Linden
Lab in 2003 that now boasts more than
500,000 residents if you have an
internet connection you can visit Second
Life as often as you like and get this a
basic second life subscription is free
so what exactly is this place we talked
to Howard Rheingold one of the early
pioneers of virtual worlds to find out
[Music]
so let's get started
the first thing you need to do is get
yourself an avatar and as will soon
discover choice abounds everywhere in
Second Life
LTS tatarskiy as one of the founders of
Lusk wood the oldest active user
community group in Second Life
you're basically free to be anyone or
anything you wish to be want to try out
being tall and muscular when in reality
you might be a little short on both
stature and exercise no problem
want to be a plate of spaghetti sure you
can do that too
now all nudity is no big deal in lots of
places in Second Life
outfitting your avatar is a whole lot of
fun and the possibilities are endless
Hamlet ow is a Second Life journalist
and the author of the making of Second
Life economically speaking the explosion
of virtual fashion industry is one of
the most significant trends in Second
Life maybe 30 40 or even 50 percent of
buying and selling in Second Life
relates to customizing the avatar head
to toe this is Callie Kline a prominent
business owner and fashion designer in
Second Life and this is her spread in
Maxim where Callie made the magazine's
Hot 100 list in 2007 I'm in the fashion
modeling business also sort of a little
niche being hired as a wrap for various
companies real life and Second Life
once you've got your avatar outfitted
it's time to explore because Second Life
is unencumbered by the laws of physics
the most popular form of travel is you
guessed it teleportation
Mimi up Scotty reach arouse one of the
many entrepreneurs making real money
developing virtual real estate in Second
Life a tree childs we offer luxury
residential living environments for
other Second Life residents to buy and
then use for their virtual homes here I
can literally move mountains in minutes
as I build landscapes
[Music]
Second Life is a bottom-up world if
there ever was one
residents created virtually everything
in second life using tools provided by
Linden Lab ever dream of touring the
great cathedrals of Europe this is the
basilica of san francesco de ceci
lovingly recreated in amazing detail by
Second Life residents if you're a Muslim
you may want to check out the virtual
Haj visitors here receive a free Haj
travel kit complete with a Quran a
prayer rug and everything else you need
to undertake a virtual pilgrimage to
Mecca mired in controversy for years the
real world monument to the victims of
9/11 is still under construction but
lots of 9/11 monuments have been created
in Second Life Liam Cano who lost loved
ones in the attack built this memorial
if you'd rather escape to something more
surreal second life is filled with
wonder lands like this oversized house
while you're here get yourself a little
green alien avatar and take a ride on a
bottle rocket or maybe you're into art
the van Gogh museum houses all of his
greatest works and at Second Life you
can enjoy a glass of absinthe inside Van
Gogh's night cafe
there's no nanny state in second life so
as you might imagine sex drugs and rock
and roll are very popular Double Down
Sandino is a professional DJ who has set
up shop in Second Life
I love clubbing but not any old clubs go
into clubs where they're alive mixed DJs
and my usual second life gangs what I
love the most
dance you're in luck
strip clubs proliferate in second life
and if you want to play out your own
personal sexual fantasy there are lots
of escort options at very reasonable
rates and just think about it in second
life you can be a gay man one day and a
straight woman the next the
possibilities are endless
so with all this diversity you think
it'd be fights breaking out all over the
place but the truth is that second life
is amazingly peaceful of course if
you're looking for violence you can find
that to most of all second life is a
massive social experiment and the people
that come here form all kinds of
communities some of which are furry if
someone says they're a furry it could
mean they just like animals or they
liked anthro that is human ish animal
type cartoons when they were a kid so
how does all this work it's simple
really the people who own the property
in second life make the rules if you
don't like nudity or people shooting at
you all you have to do is teleport
somewhere else it's very much like what
Robert Nozick imagined in Anarchy state
and utopia a plethora of alternate
societies communism is mostly dead in
real life but even the communists have a
happy home in second life and don't
worry these communists aren't gonna
throw you into a gulag they're not in
power and no one else seems to be either
so who exactly is in charge here hey
guys who's your leader I'm not sure we
have one
I'm my own leader nice to meet you
second life is interesting and I think
successful because of the freedom it
grants
to create their own entertainment I
would say it's fairly anarchistic and
that everyone more or less is allowed to
do what they want
so long as it doesn't hurt or offend
other people you know Kali this much
freedom scares a lot of people
Washington Post columnist and former
Bush speechwriter Michael Gerson for
example calls this place a quote seedy
derelict carnival Mike you should have
let me take you around you missed out on
so much compared to the real life second
life has a lot of freedom but recently
they banned gambling and banking and
imposed restrictions on advertising on
the mainland don't worry though if the
London government gets too big for its
britches we'll be able to emigrate to
other virtual frontiers a few hundred
years ago adventurous europeans tired of
monarchies and religious oppression
risked everything to seek out new
opportunities in the wilds of america
today people everywhere can explore this
new virtual frontier without risk at the
click of a button so next time you're at
a computer take a trip to second life in
the world give it a try I truly believe
there is something for everyone here
take it slow and don't be afraid to ask
the locals for some direction and if you
do come visit seriously drop me a note
card and let me know you saw the show
that would be so amazing for reason TV
I'm drew here
[Music]
[Music]